i put this out on my uh facebook page
um i'm just gonna pin this up at the top
just for a little bit anyway
um i put it out on my
community page sorry not facebook on
youtube and
what was the question we put out here do
men have an obligation to save the west
or should we just take care of ourselves
let's just put it up on the screen here
so i can show you guys sure screen boom
boom boom
that's it
and uh
35 of you said yes we must save the west
and 65 said nope let it burn i'm tired
of the bs
so i'm going to approach this from both
angles
tonight
just to kind of um
try to look at it from two different
perspectives and i'll tell you at the
end what my perspective is i know some
of you guys already think you know and
you may or may not be right but i'll let
you guys know i'm going to be taking
some call-ins tonight so if you're a
guy with some solutions i
want to hear from you i'm going to drop
the join link you guys can join in on
the cast hopefully you've got some
solutions to this problem because it is
a problem i mean let's talk about the
problem first but um
and um you know we can chop it up a
little bit live um show's gonna run for
90 minutes it might go a little bit
longer tonight because this will this
will probably be a very interesting one
and i'm sure we'll get some good
call-ins on it but um we got here in the
chat from uh from the early boys we got
a super chat early on thank you rich for
your work you're the most one of the
most reasonable voices out there i'm
focused on my journey but sometimes i'm
getting distracted by these weak
politicians and the decisions they make
politics is a big part of it too so
we're going to talk about that as well
uh my boy infamous rifle says they don't
deserve to be saved my tennis will work
on myself and improve my own life that
is the only thing i am in control of the
west has become a decadent and needs a
reset
i think we could talk about resetting as
well it's an interesting perspective
so this is a great conversation um
i often think about this because
you know when you're on social media
and it comes mostly from like trad con
twitter and social pages like um
i think ryan calls it like miller light
masculinity which is like
um you know they drink miller light have
a couple babies
have a work shed in the back uh grow a
beard and uh shoot bows and arrows and
maybe guns you know from time to time
and you know the notion is uh get
married put babies in her and save the
west
okay that is a approach it's one
approach
but does it save the west let's talk
about the problem
so
i think if you're going to go to any one
area because i mean you can talk about
all kinds of different things here you
can talk about
economics schooling children you know
the state of masculinity femininity
um you know these these toxic versions
of them and all that sort of stuff but i
think the one leading area that is
the clearest
to look at when evaluating
an empire because you know empires have
always existed we live in an empire
today you know the west is
technically an empire okay but roman
empire is a greek ottoman so on and so
forth
they all came and went
okay they all became
big
they all had reached influence and they
no longer had it
cyclical right these things happen
that's just the way that it works
nothing's forever
they're either on the rise or they're on
the decline you're either growing or
you're dying you can't you can't be in
between
i don't see
much in the way of improvement right now
okay so
the problem as it's defined you know as
i was talking about earlier the problem
is really things are not good you know
if things were good people wouldn't be
saying well let's save the west you know
the the trad con twitter guy is a miller
light masculinity guys the
um
there's all these like masculinity
groups i'm going to do that in
quotations for those of you that are
listening on you know the podcast
version of this but there's all kinds of
masculinity groups
out there that like to um
sell this narrative you know this uh
notion that
if you just do the right thing things
will get better right and i've said this
before and i wrote about it in my book
as well they tell men and women two
totally different things they tell men
you do what's right
they tell women you do what's right for
you girl
okay
yeah
roll those in the chat masculinity
larpers bingo
so the problem is
and it can be
viewed very clearly by looking at
people's voting patterns because people
cast votes i know that there's a lot of
folks out there that say that
uh the system's rigged democracy's
broken
mail-in ballots blah blah blah and all
sort of stuff it's not working and you
know um
there was
underhanded things that happened i'm
trying to water this down a little bit
for youtube you guys know how it goes
but
specific to north america we'll talk
about canada and the us i'm not super
familiar with british um politics
as i was in the past but western
countries primarily consist of you know
english-speaking modern you know there's
a lot of european countries that are
also very modern and western as well
they would be inclusive you know guys
like macron you know in france
um there's all kinds of
these western leaders that people are
voting for which are not contributing to
the ascent
to the betterment of society
and all you've got to do is take a look
at the state of things right
um what we got going on here trying to
catch up on a few of these dude is desi
hey rich uh shy shike here i think the
west has forgotten so much i don't know
a lot but this will reverse
well stay tuned brother you're gonna
find out oh um sorry before i forget i
always try to do this to try to just
help with the algorithms if you guys can
do me solid uh come over to
youtube just click this link if you're
watching this like on twitter or any of
the other platforms it just helps me a
ton hit the like button just to give it
a thumbs up oh it's the wrong one did i
hit the wrong one i hit the wrong one
sorry
that's the cultivate crypto one for the
this one here
that's it click that one if you're
watching somewhere else
thank you all right
and when you get there hit that like
button helps me out
got 200 likes 500 change people watching
hit that like button get those likes up
so what's the problem it's messed up out
there it's you know it's a problem
because everybody's trying to solve it
and
there's two camps it's let's fix this
let's mind our own business and and fix
ourselves
and they both think they're right
it you know if you wanted to sell it
down to the two camps
the let's fix it crowd again it's the uh
miller like masculinity guys it's just
you know wife up wife her up put a bunch
of babies in her and we're gonna save
things but the environmental conditions
that we're living in because you don't
have autonomy anymore as a guy you know
you're no longer the head of your
household i talk about that in my book
in several chapters the unplugged alpha
you can get it on amazon as the title of
the podcast suggests
the state is the head of the household
and
for a very very long time
men
ruled their world they you know
they were the king of their castles
that's that doesn't exist anymore the
state runs things and
it's gotten itself to a place that
varies depending on where you're living
state or province you know in north
america for example i know that's where
most of the views come from
depending on where you're living um
there's different things that have been
happening that have contributed to
the decline that the miller like
masculinity guys are trying to save
i'll give a great example one of the
things that drives me nuts you know
lately is
i recently learned that a 12 year old
kid
well a 12 year old kid let's put it this
way they can't drive a car
they can't vote
they can't drink alcohol they can't buy
weed they can't do any of those things
that are technically available to 16 19
and older
you know kids or as they turn into
adults
but at 12 years old they can make their
own medical decisions
believe it or not here in ontario
so
the way that the government
seems to be leveraging this position
is with this whole
let's get everybody jabbed narrative
because it's better for us
we'll deal with the
sides of whether it is or it isn't some
other time but you know the government
wants to impose their beliefs on you on
your household on your children you
don't have governance over your own
children anymore now they're going to be
putting vaccination clinics in school
this fall i believe i've seen the
writing on the wall they haven't
announced it yet but this is where i
think it's going
which means that they're going to be
luring 12 year old and up because if
you're 12 or older they can make medical
decisions on their own like this
they're going to be luring 12 year old
kids to come and get jabbed because all
the cool kids are doing it
okay
that's a problem
the whole like the whole selling point
of having children is that your name
your dna your beliefs your values can be
imposed on your offspring and passed
down into perpetuity
now the government's saying
sorry mr cooper we're going to make that
decision for you and we've decided that
we think it's better that we do this and
we're going to pass a law that says that
12 year olds can make these choices and
then we're now going to
uh offer them lollipops and candy and
stuff like that which is probably you
know how they're going to roll with it
it's insane
it's insane and i keep seeing versions
of this time and time and time and time
again there was another
news piece i saw in the last 14 days
there was a parent i think was a mom
in chicago
that a judge decided unilaterally
decided that she was not a fit parent
because she did not take the vaccine
and i'm not sure if she lost custody or
had reduced custody or if it went into
productive services the child itself
but
that's how things roll now
how can you save the west
and i'm asking this question
legitimately how can you save the west
if you don't have control of over
your offspring
starting with that alone you know your
kids because this is what the state
seems to be doing i'm going to put a
poll up here as i'm talking right
uh can men
save the west and it's just a yes or no
answer i'm not going gonna
leave it up for too too long so it's
those of you that are watching this live
rola says you can't say solve new order
problems with old order thinking
jimbo's on there years ago i was in the
save at camp but the red pill changed my
mindset
and i don't think that that's a
doomer approach to it if i can be honest
right it's not like
you know you unplug
you see the code in a matrix and you
understand things for what they are
you've read my book you've read rollo's
books any of the other stuff that i've
recommended
it's not like you unplug and it's like
oh that said it's over
there's still the mental point of origin
component of it which i'm going to be
talking about as well right because you
do have control over your life
but how do you save the west when you
don't have control or influence and
people don't seem to want it saved so
let's deal with that part people don't
seem to want it safe because i think
that's an important component of it if
you watch people's voting patterns
based on what candidates stand for and
here let me pull up the the recent polls
in canada so we can see where we're at
here because we have an election going
on right now so this is
this is very timely uh canadian polls
let's see where we're at
we're tracking
this is the most recent one that i saw i
think here
pulling canada boom okay share
uh to do at the screen
hope you guys can see that
so um i'm just going to break these down
to describe before because we have a few
more political parties than you guys do
in the yes and in the us that get
tracked in the polls uh lpc is a liberal
party
cpc is the conservative party can we
make this bigger there we go cpc is a
conservative party ndp is essentially a
socialist party
gpc is the green party
global warming you know it's save the
baby seals the block quebecois is a
separatist party they basically want to
have quebec separate from the rest of
canada
and the people's party of canada the ppc
is max bernier's party which is more of
a libertarian freedom-based party
so
before you go around thinking that
you're going to save the west by
drinking your miller like growing a
beard and living in a shed in your
backyard and putting babies in your wife
you've got to understand how does the
how does your nation vote what does your
nation think of the direction of
politics what is your what does your
nation cast a vote for
what is it that they
view as the best choice the best
direction because all of these people
collectively get to decide
the direction that things go and the
government's quite clever at this right
long time ago
they were small government
you could only cast a vote if you had
property rights so if you're a property
owner you know you cast a vote women
weren't able to vote until you know very
recently
democracy has been around for a while
the greeks invented a long long time ago
they used to do it with stones there
would be like a white stone and a black
stone and you'd take your stone you'd
put in a basket and they you know count
the stones afterwards you know sort of
thing that's how they did the polling
you know for the electoral stuff
concept's been around for a long long
time ancient greece has had it for a
while right so
now it's involved you know evolved into
a situation where government has
realized well if we have people
with no skin in the game voting for
policies that benefit them that they
don't contribute to and i'm and i'm
saying this you know blanketly you know
in a balance of probabilities you've got
to understand this
then this is what then this is where we
end up with and after decades and
decades of all this stuff
i'm gonna i'm gonna get to some of these
super chats in a second just stand by
guys
and after decades and decades of all
this stuff this is where we've ended up
where people vote like justin trudeau
has won the last two canadian elections
and i'm sure you're familiar with him
because i know a lot of people don't
like him and i know a lot of people seem
to like him
there's enough people that like him that
he is still the prime minister of canada
and could potentially win this election
will he i don't know we'll see
but people are voting for his policies
what is policies include inclusiveness
wokeness inclusiveness
rainbows inclusiveness
high taxes
um ultra rich uh
taxes you know let's let's let's let's
bend over the guys that are doing the
work and creating jobs and employing
people and tax them more
and more social programs more social
programs more free stuff more social
programs more wokeness more political
correctness more censorship more control
more lockdowns more jobs more passports
that's what this that's what this party
stands for the only party
on the other side of the equation that
contributes to saving the west which
nobody seems to vote for
okay we don't need
more social programs we don't need more
government
government's important it needs to
provide the function of
maintaining the roads
fire services policing national defense
stuff like that you could argue about
health care and other things kind of in
between but it's gotten to the point
where it's overreach beyond it's
actually gotten to the point now where
they're going to
do things that are going to
potentially conflict with your own
belief system with your own 12 year old
children
you have a 12 year old kid in school
and they want to jab them
what are you going to do you're going to
take them out of the school system you
can homeschool them sure that's one
option
but when are they going to get them are
they going to get them when they're 15
or 16 when they're 18 you know
it's difficult to say right
but the polling uh
and what people vote for i think is
important it's not that much different
in the united states you know i mean
individual states are better i have a
lot of friends in many of the different
states they're very close friends of
mine i know exactly what's going on in
their lives and what they think of all
of this stuff too
but it's very very similar in the united
states i mean overall from a national
perspective
you've got
joe biden as president
what does he stand for pretty much the
same thing as justin trudeau
big taxes
wokeness political correctness
you know the same sort of stuff that i
just ticked off how is it that much
different
is it much different but that's what
people are
casting their vote for and that's
and the governance part of things is
what you have to look at how do you
change the government's part of things
when only four percent of people in
canada right now
and i'm you know moving my cursor over
the ppc one which has four percent
in in the polls for those of you that
are listening and not watching
only four percent of the population is
basically saying yeah we need more
freedom smaller government lower taxes
you know basically get out of my life
government right that's that's generally
the angle that that you want is you want
more mobility you want more freedom and
you don't want the government imposing
beliefs on you that you don't
necessarily agree with
you don't even have exemptions here in
canada right now because of
religious beliefs
dietary restrictions the only two
exemptions right now that you have where
i live
if you don't want to take the job or
participate in the vaccine passport
is you have to have a proven allergy
okay
and you just can't say you don't have an
allergy you actually have to say i have
an allergy and then it has to be proven
by
whatever technician you know tests you
for that allergy and then you have it
you have to produce another piece of
paper to
circumvent the other piece of paper that
forces you to get the vaccine so there's
that
and the other option is you took the
first jab and you had a bad reaction to
it and again you have to have a medical
professional write you a letter saying
that in their opinion
it wouldn't be wise for you to continue
taking these jobs because it wouldn't
you know serve your health
that's it
there's a lot of arguments up out there
whether or not it's a violation of
charter rights the nuremberg blah blah
blah not sort of stuff but that's where
you're at
right
so
for those of you that want to
come at this with a solution
because i again like i i am inviting
people constantly on my show if you
disagree with something that i say
come at me with a solution what is what
is your better solution i have not heard
anybody attempt to approach us from a
different angle yet
let me catch up on these super chats so
they don't disappear up here um
andrew's travel says vaccine is deadly
one of the world's one world reset okay
i'll talk about the reset in a second
because like because i keep hearing
reset reset reset
standby
until they get rid of the sources that
invite hypergamy men can't save them
okay i'm going to deal with this for a
second
social media has ruined dating
so ryan's saying until they get rid of
the sources that invite hypergamy
you want to remove social media screens
cell phones technology wi-fi bluetooth
cell phone towers let's say you get rid
of all that stuff do you think women are
going to stop being hypergamous do you
think women are going to stop
considering better options if you remove
cell phones do you think women are going
to stop considering a better option if
tick tock and instagram just blow up and
disappear overnight
that's in women's nature it is a
survival mechanism read some
evolutionary psychology okay
i've got pinned books i've got a pin
comment on top of all my videos not a
lot of you guys pay attention to this
because it's like you watch the video or
sometimes you watch you know you see the
title and then you're in the comments
right away writing a response you didn't
even watch the damn [ __ ] video
pin in the top comment there's a list of
useful links
one of them is an amazon link to books
that i recommend guys read and in there
there's some stuff with evolutionary
psychology most of you guys out there
running mouth on things like hypergamy
don't understand what you're talking
about it's innate to their survival if
women weren't hypergamous we would not
have the society that we have today if
your grandmothers your great
grandmothers and all the way down the
chain 10 000 years ago were not
hypergamous we would not be here today
do you guys understand that
it's part it's it's it's a feature it's
not a bug okay removing social media or
platforms or only fans is not going to
make it go away
it's just going to give her less access
to the attention that's the only
difference
do do um rich have you seen hacking
democracy it's a must-watch haven't seen
it uh let me know where it's at if it's
like netflix amazon
let me know
decentralization is the way to go yeah
uh decentralization solves a lot of the
problems when it comes to the financial
system which is another broken component
of society that
i don't see fake like there's no way the
government is going to fix
money problems
inflationary issues are huge there's
inherent problems with all fiat
currencies
and the centralized nature of it just
like it's just a matter of time before
we move off fiat currency is it going to
be on the blockchain that's where i
would place my bets which is why i'm so
bullish on things like you know charlie
and miguel teaching people how to
acquire cryptocurrency and why it's
important
haters don't like it hey if you hate me
for saying that then buy and hold the us
dollar robert kiyosaki was on with rolo
the other week and that was one of the
things that like
leapt off the screen at me if you if you
trust the government so much and if you
think that's the way to go keep buying
and holding us dollars okay
um i live in california and currently we
have a recall election going on it would
be
i would love to see given nuisance uh
for gap gone okay but who's who's he
going to be replaced by because again
uh add to stream
and remove that
this is what people vote for these are
the patterns in north america we see
people voting for
socialist and liberalist sort of
patterns
liberalism
you know
jack donovan calls it the empire of
nothing he's not wrong
um
if more people read thomas so well then
we wouldn't be having these pro yep see
the thing that you got to understand
about
humans unpopular movie opinions
the things that you really got to
understand about humans there's a
netflix documentary called uh how to be
a tyrant
and um
one of the things that popped off on
that one was that throughout history for
a very long period of time
human beings have loved a ruler
does it matter if it's
a high priest a king a queen a god
whatever it is humans love being ruled
we always have been
and the other day i was watching one of
my sailing videos you know as i do it's
pretty much all that i'll spend time
watching on youtube now
and um
they were doing this like tour on the
yucatan you know peninsula and i've been
there i've seen kobo i've seen you know
chichen itza and all that sort of stuff
and i've been in the cenotes and swam
them all and they're doing a tour and it
was interesting from the perspective
because he was talking about how society
at that time and the mayan civilization
was very very advanced
if you want to learn more about that
graham hancock has some great books if
you don't want to read his books look up
graham hancock and joe rogan interviews
guy's a freaking genius the stuff that
he's discovered
um
about
society and ancient civilizations is
just stunning
but
back to the point of the mine uh you
know civilization they they rally
together to build giant stone
structures and pyramids and they've only
been tracking hurricanes for i think the
last 150 or 200 years if i'm not
mistaken it hasn't been a long time
um in north america and there's been a
lot of hurricanes that have hit the
yucatan peninsula and none of these
stone structures have collapsed they've
built them properly despite what
alarmists and global warmness have been
saying like this is all a function of
local global warming and services
they've been on for millions of years
but the mayans built these giant sturdy
stone structures around either a king
or a high priest okay somebody that
ruled in that area
people love being ruled
right people love being ruled so here we
go
societies come and go i think empires
come and go egyptians greek romans
ottoman you know the mayan like
the they all had greatest sense glory
and
leave things behind i don't know what
we're going to leave behind
you know as the west but you get the
idea
you know reading books informs you
voting for
you know a different governor may change
things temporarily
but
as my old man always you know seem to
say like the pendulum just swings from
one side to the other it's like boom
boom boom boom nobody ever kind of like
goes and votes for
one of these guys over here that run a
libertarian party that give you your
personal freedom and your autonomy
they just don't
ask yourself what are the voting
patterns right
the only way to save the west stop
paying attention to the woke mob cancel
cable mainstream media these people have
a small minority yet are the loudest i
can't say for sure
[Music]
how many like what percentage of the
population is woke cancel cultured you
know the offspring of the cairns but
there's a lot of them out there
and
again the voting patterns tell you the
voting patterns tell you they just don't
lie
right i can tell you right now here in
canada the voting patterns for the woke
go for the liberal party the ndp jagmeet
singh who i worked with about 10 years
ago when i was lobbying on bill 55 who
lied to my face
these people are who they're voting for
okay and even the conservative party in
canada now has been criticized for being
basically blue red
meaning they're like liberal light
pretty much the same thing
you know they support a lot of the same
policies that justin trudeau does so
it's not like you're going to see a big
change if you vote for the conservative
party here
all right
let's go back here how are we doing with
this poll what did you guys say
can men save the west yes or no pretty
much the same split 57 percent said no
43 said yes close to 500 votes
you